you know we hear from the witnesses but
the FBI isn't interviewing them and
isn't giving us any facts so all we have
you're you're doing it senator I'm sorry
to interrupt but you're doing it that's
that there's no conclusions reached that
was Brent Cavanaugh responding to
Senator Dianne Feinstein of California
today's hearing he's we spoke with
retired Harvard professor Alan
Dershowitz ahead of today's hearing now
that it's over what did he think the
outcome professor Dershowitz also of
course the author of the best-selling
the case against impeaching Trump and he
rejoins us tonight professor thanks a
lot for coming on you watched the
hearing from beginning to end what's
your assessment well when I watched her
I really thought she was extremely
credible and I had grave doubts as to
whether he could win the credibility
contest but then he made this remarkable
comeback and he really testified in a
completely compelling manner so I think
in the end there is a tie when it comes
to personal credibility so how do you
break the tie I think one way is to look
for corroboration and he has much more
corroboration on his side now the best
way to make sure that corroboration is
accurate is for the committee to call
the other witnesses and let the FBI
continue its background check and I
think in the end it will do him more
good than harm now when we spoke
yesterday you said that you were
concerned about the choice of Rachel
Mitchell from the Maricopa County sex
crime investigations office in Arizona
to speak on behalf of Republican
senators as they questioned Christine
forded your point what well I think we
have a clip I'll show you your point
sure see the greatest engine of truth
ever invented used effectively namely
cross-examination and I'm worried that
we don't have the right people the woman
who has been hired to conduct the
cross-examination has probably rarely
ever cross-examined anybody she's a
prosecutor so I don't think she's the
right person to question dr. Ford you
know I was criticized very much for
making that point and I turned out to be
100% right she was totally and
completely incompetent in terms of
asking cross-examination question
because she has little experience for
example the main issue now is whether or
not she recognized Kavanagh correctly
she was never asked whether how well she
knew him how many times she encountered
him before this how close was their
relationship there was nothing that
could raise questions about whether even
if she believes she's telling the truth
she may have misidentified so she just
did a terrible job and I think the
Republicans realize that and they candor
right in the middle but it was a very
bad choice
so can I and those of us who asked
questions for a living sat and watched
with our mouths open wondering
throughout what is the point of this not
that she's a bad person or stupid but no
you would think I mean you've been
around congressional testimony before
you've been you've testified when you
are asking questions of a witness
aren't you doing so in order to prove a
point tell a story you're doing so for
some reason aren't you you have to have
a theory every question has to be part
of a tactic you ask question a in order
to lay a foundation for B she was just
asking questions
it just didn't seem to go anywhere she
didn't have much of a point and in the
end she accomplished nothing yes Brett
Kavanaugh defended himself nobody else
was other than Lindsey Graham Thank You
professor it's great to see you and I
just wanted to let our viewers know what
a prescient prediction you mean the
truth come out we're all interested in
thank you professor